this video is made possible by backblaze
get a 15 day free trial at backblaze.com
forward slash biographics
[Music]
a total disregard for his own personal
safety an indomitable
fighting spirit reckless courage and the
gift of
being nearly indestructible this soldier
survived
five wars including world war one and
world war ii and became one of the most
decorated british officers of all time
and sustained countless injuries was he
the
unluckiest soldier of all time or maybe
just the quintessential british war hero
well make up your own mind as we hear
the story of today's protagonist
adrian carten dewitt the unbreakable
soldier
adrian carten-duyet was born into an
aristocratic family in brussels belgium
on may
5th 1880. the father of this
quintessential british war hero was
actually belgium
and a lawyer his mother well she was
actually irish adrian was so belgium in
fact that
throughout his life he was amused by the
rumor that he was an illegitimate child
of king leopold ii who owned the congo
adrian's mother sadly passed away when
he was just six and his father lyon
moved the family to cairo
in egypt during this period leon married
again and adrian's stepmother thought it
was a good idea for the boys education
if they were to spend some time
at a british boarding school as the
family was catholic he was sent to a
catholic school the
oratory near birmingham the founder of
the school cardinal john henry newman
once wrote
fear not that thy life shall come to an
end but
rather fear that it shall never have a
beginning
adrian's life would be on the brink of
coming to an end
countless times but he never showed any
fear and for sure his life
it certainly had a hell of a beginning
by 1899 adrian was 19 he was attending
balial college at oxford
at this stage in his life as per his
father's desire he could have easily
settled for a law degree
and the pleasant existence of a typical
toff just enjoying his family's wealth
except
he didn't
[Music]
on the 11th of october 1899 the second
bar war broke out pitting the british
empire
against the orange free state and the
transvaal republic in south africa this
was a revelation for adrian
in his autobiography happy odyssey he
wrote at that moment i knew once and for
all that
war was in my blood if the british
didn't fancy me i would offer myself
to the boers it turns out the brits they
did fancy him adrian enrolled as a
volunteer faking his identity
as well as his age he was soon
dispatched to south africa while his
father still believed him to be studying
law
at oxford and this was the start of his
real life
a soldier's life very early on straight
after training in south africa dewort
and his unit were crossing a river in
full view of some bur commandos when he
was shot twice
once in the stomach and once in the
groin so we're going to help you out
here and keep count of how many times he
was
shot or shrapnelled or otherwise just
injured
after being shot a superior bluntly
asked if there were many buzz about
which she replied coolly
no but the few were very good shots
in the hospital his identity was
discovered and so he was forced to
return to england to recover
and to face his father's wrath who by
now discovered what his son was up to
luckily leont consented and his son
pursued a military career and
after adrian returned he decided to quit
oxford for good and return to south
africa in 1901 for another round of
fighting
this time though he did it in style
booking himself in first
class and handing generous tips to the
bar staff so
that he landed in cape town with exactly
one
pound in my pocket after joining a
cavalry regiment duart was promoted to
corporal this promotion lasted exactly
24 hours after which he was demoted
again to simple trooper for
threatening to hit a sergeant but it was
clear to dwight that he was destined to
greater things and after a few months he
had earned or more probably
bought a commission a second lieutenant
during the rest of 1901 and until the
end of the second burr war in 1902
duarte greatly suffered for the lack of
action his only opportunity to do
anything of military value was to cut
some barbed wire in a burr
camp but even then he was ordered not to
do it fretting for action
at the end of the war he applied to be
sent to british somaliland to join the
hunt for muhammad bin abdullah also
known as the mad mullah bin abdullah
had started a guerrilla campaign against
the british east african colony and he
was
fighting for independence and considered
by his followers
a sunni holy man and almost a messiah
but to colonial authorities he wasn't a
messiah he was just a rather
naughty boy again duarte superiors they
curbed his fighting enthusiasm and he
was gazetted to a cavalry regiment in
matra in india the indian stay was
peaceful and largely uneventful except
for duart finding
a great passion for pig sticking which
basically consists in chasing wild boar
on horseback through the forest to
pierce them with a long spear
anyway when chasing one of these pigs in
the jungle duet fell off the horse and
the horse fell
on him and cracked several ribs and one
ankle
during his convalescence he had an
argument with the local servant and
pelted him with
stones when the servants got out of
range daward shot him in the butt
and at this point it's pretty clear that
this guy was in dire
need of battle his superiors they were
not amused by the attack on the servant
though and they jailed him for a time
but
he did manage to avoid demotion
in 1904 dwight was transferred back to
south africa he wrote in his memoirs
that he was happy not to see india again
i suppose the feeling was probably
mutual on that one the ensuing years
they were blissful towards spent his
time gambling socializing racing horses
and shooting wildlife
he enjoyed several liquid meals as he
called them but
also cultivated his physical fitness at
one point he was so strong that he could
rip in half a pack of cards in 1907
duarte swore an oath of allegiance to
the king
formally becoming a british citizen
within the british army
in 1908 duid returned to england where
his few regimental duties gave him time
to play polo and
travel the continent and especially
austria-hungary to shoot grouse
pheasants another game
in the same year his connection to that
empire was strengthened by his marriage
to frederick maria caroline henriette
rosa sabina franziska fugo von
babenhausen and no he had not become a
mormon who married seven different women
this was the full name of the bride in
austrian countess
they went on to have two daughters
together in his memoirs dwight recalls
the atmosphere of mistrust at
german border posts whenever he entered
the country from france and how his
french-sounding surname attracted
suspicion a clear
sign that tension was mounting and that
war was certainly on the horizon
you probably knew that one when world
war one broke out duarte was on his way
to british somaliland to take part in
what is now
a mostly forgotten conflict the colonial
war against the mad muller who we
introduced earlier duart's desire to go
and fight there it had finally been
fulfilled but upon learning that the uk
had declared war on germany though it
felt like
playing in a village qriket match
instead of in the test
and for our friends in the us here the
test is to cricket what the world series
is to baseball eduard was assigned to
lead a squadron of the somaliland camel
corps
on the hunt for the mad muller's
followers that are wishes when tasked
with storming an enemy fort duarte could
not
resist going on the attack head first
but the enemy position it was well
defended
and he was shot by the dervishers three
times
in the face indeed one bullet took part
of his left ear a second bullet got him
in the left eye and a third bullet
ricocheted and hit him across
the very same eye of course duarte
lost his eye but his assessment of the
battle it had all been most exhilarating
then
duane took the occasion to return to
england where he hoped to be reassigned
to service on the western front the army
medical commission agreed to it provided
that he used a glass eye which he hated
indeed while riding in a cab in london
and finding the glass-side too
uncomfortable he just
yanked it out and threw it out of the
taxi window from then on he would wear
his distinctive
eye patch okay now just before we get
into his actions
on the western front i do want to tell
you a little bit about today's sponsor
backblaze now our sponsors really they
do make it possible so
we can make long videos just like this
several times a week so
when you go to use one of their services
because the links that we put in the
description it really does make a
difference to what we do and
it really does allow us to keep doing it
so if you think backblaze is for you why
not just click that
and check it out it's amazing now
backplace is the best way to back up all
of your files now as you guys know i do
test out all of the sponsors that appear
on this
show and indeed i am using backblaze to
back up all of my files both
as we record this video and as you are
watching it so as we speak my files
are being securely synced with
backblaze's servers now my computer's
just
sitting over there it's churning away in
the background and does that all day and
all night just uploading the gigabytes
upon
gigabytes of videos that i make every
day just
syncing with their servers so i never
have to worry about backing anything up
i can just rest assured the backblaze is
taking care of all of that
and it's also doing all of my files and
other important stuff like that that i
don't want to ever risk losing
[Music]
now fortunately touching the fake
plastic wood on my chair
i've never had to call on them but if
you do have a problem you can download
files directly i'd do that because i got
a super fast internet connection but if
i had a major failure like one of my
giant hard disks went out they will
actually
ship you a hard disk all encrypted all
nice and safe so that you can just
plug it straight into your computer or
you can transfer the files or you can
just keep the disk and pay them a fee
it's and it's all super reasonable
also all changes to files are
automatically backed up so it's all
it's really just a hands-off experience
and if you're watching this you can get
a 15-day free
trial right now you can click the link
below or just go
to backblaze.com forward slash
biographics get that peace of mind and
supporting backblaze supports us which
is awesome so don't put it off click
that link maybe open in a new tab and
just try out that 15 day trial
you love it i'm pretty sure of it and
let's get back to the western front
in february 1915 adrian carten dwight
was bound
for the western front to join a cavalry
regiment the fourth
royal irish dragoon guards his first
major
engagement was during the second battle
of eprin april of that year
while on march to relieve an infantry
unit his regiment came
under fire from a german artillery
position a combination of shrapnel and
splinters from his own wristwatch
mangled his left hand leaving only part
of the palm
and two dangling fingers when the field
doctor hesitated to amputate them do it
just
tore off the two remaining fingers what
remained of his hand would be later
amputated
at this point he could have easily asked
to be repatriated and just have a quiet
life
behind a desk but he didn't zohar
could not give two hoots about his
injuries and he just got on with it
returning to battle undeterred
and unimpaired we'd like to think of
this pointed story that he probably
exclaimed tis but
a scratch and then returned to battle he
then went on to fight in the battle of
the song during which his men recall him
pulling pins from grenades with his
teeth and then
flinging them with his one good hand
into enemy territory he distinguished
himself during the assault on the
village of la boisel in france in 1916.
three unit commanders from the 8th
battalion gloucestershire regiment had
been killed
dwight then took charge of all three
units with no availability of field
radios
field telephones nor even pigeons to
communicate orders he decided to be his
own messenger and ran back and forth
along the three units to relay his
orders defying the hail of bullets and
artillery shells reigning onto no man's
land he and his men
managed to hold back the advancing
germans after this action
dwight received the victoria cross for
most conspicuous bravery coolness and
determination during severe operations
of prolonged nature
this was the citation after this dwart
continued to lead from the front battle
after battle exposing himself to further
injuries
for example in the trenches of delville
wood nicknamed the devil's wood he was
actually shot in the head it was a clean
straight shot
through his skull right to the back of
the head if he had to die
well this would be the right occasion to
do so except he didn't
apparently dwight didn't care for being
dead so he simply survived and
got on with it during three subsequent
battles he was shot in the ankle
hip leg and ear but after every stay in
hospital he regained full mobility and
returned to the front
time after time dua's assessment of this
grueling experience of the meat grinder
of the western front was
frankly i enjoyed the war
[Music]
the years between world war one and the
start of world war ii uh often wrongly
labelled the interwar
years because this period it actually
saw a lot of conflicts taking place in
europe
and while there was conflict you'd be
sure to find adrian
carten to wyatt i mean the time of his
life in 1919 duart was assigned to
poland as a military advisor to the
newly independent country which over a
period of two years
found itself at war with soviet russia
czech slovakia
ukraine and lithuania dwight made
himself indispensable to field marshal
joseph pulseedski and as usual he got
involved in all types of risky
situations
the same year in 1919 he survived not
one but two plane crashes
the second of these crashes resulted in
a brief period of captivity with the
lithuanians after his release he
increased his efforts to support the
polish military even organizing a gun
smuggling operation
via hungary in 1920 he got closer to the
front as
the war with russia intensified one day
his observation train was attacked by a
charge of cossack cavalry with the
intent of hijacking it
he confronted the attackers
single-handedly quite literally
with his revolver at one point he even
fell off the moving train but quickly
leapt back
on it and continued the firefight until
the train escaped from the cossacks when
the polish wars finally ended in victory
in 1921 dewitt decided to stay in poland
as he had grown fond of its people
and its wildlife which he proceeded to
shoot for the next 18 years
the wildlife that is not the people in
1923 he finally decided to retire having
now achieved the rank of major general
after a life of adventures this
gentleman would go on to lead
a quiet and wealthy life in his adopted
country
except he didn't
we all know what happened on the 1st of
september 1939.
in a matter of three weeks germany
invaded from the west the soviet union
from the east and the uk and france
declared
war on the axis powers though its quiet
life in poland
it was no more as a former british
military adviser the best course of
action was to flee immediately he
abandoned his estate
acquired a fake passport and crossed the
border with romania
upon returning to the uk dwight
reenlisted in the military in april 1940
duet was recalled into active service
despite
and i should stress this again in case
you've forgotten being
60 one-eyed and an amputee he was given
the rank of acting lieutenant general
and
tasked with leading an anglo-french
landing force in norway
to halt the german invasion this
operation there was a complete disaster
from the start
while arriving in norway via seaplane
dwight's aircraft
was forced to crash land this happened
on a ford where it was then attacked
by a german fighter plane rather than
boarding a rubber dinghy to reach shore
and become a sitting duck he calmly
waited in the wreckage until the enemy
plane
ran out of ammo and left after reaching
his forces by the trondheim ford dwyad
realized that they were under supplied
undergunned and soon to be encircled by
the germans but dwight
you might imagine he didn't really care
about the odds being stacked against him
and he just got on with it his troops
they managed to break the encirclements
by
traversing over the mountains and back
to the coast under a constant barrage of
artillery strikes and
luftwaffe attacks finally the royal navy
came to the rescue and managed to ferry
duart and his band of brothers out of
norway
and they landed in great britain on his
60th birthday in april 1941
carton dewitt was appointed by winston
churchill to lead a british secret
mission
in yugoslavia the objective was to make
contact with tito's partisans and offer
them allied support
but he never got there after a
refuelling stop in malta the wellington
bomber in which the mission was
traveling went into a nosedive straight
into the mediterranean
luckily there was a coastline inside as
the fuselage sank dwyat
61 one-handed and one eyed swamped
ashore while carrying an
injured comrade also the coast they had
reached was the coast of libya
axis territory and dwyat and his friends
they were immediately seized by the
italians
our hero today was transported by the
italian military to the high security
pow camp
established within the castle of vinci
eliata near florence
this prison was specifically dedicated
to guarding senior british officers
captured in north africa
the average age of the prisoners was 52
but these indomitable officers
they had the energy of young soldiers
when it came to breaking out dwyat was a
part of at least
five escape attempts one of which
involved digging a 60-foot tunnel
under the castle walls this was
certainly a complicated endeavor for an
amputee
but as usual dwight didn't give a damn
about it
and he just got on with it after seven
months the tunnel was complete dwight
and five other prisoners succeeded in
their great escape in march of 1943
and hid for some days in their
countryside their cunning plan was to
make themselves inconspicuous by
dressing like italian peasants so yes
considering that one of them was a
one-handed 63 year old gentleman with an
eye patch covered in scars and none of
them could speak italian
it was sort of a miracle that they
managed to escape capture for eight
days duas he was soon back in captivity
at the castle though
fun fact by the way this castle can now
be hired for weddings if you're
interested
but freedom was on the horizon on june
25th of 1943 benito mussolini was ousted
by
a monarchist coup king victor emmanuel
iii appointed field marshal badoglio as
his successor and the two conspirators
continued honoring the alliance with
germany but
only on the surface behind the scenes
they were looking to negotiate an
armistice with the allies
they needed an intermediary and dwight
he seemed to be the perfect choice as he
was due for release from the castle
anyway because of his disability
duarte was taken to a tailor in rome so
that he could get some civilian clothes
as a loyal customer of civil row he
didn't trust the italian tailors and he
protested that he didn't want to look
like a gigolo
but in the end he was happy with the
suit that they fashioned for him and on
the 16th of august 1943 he was flown
in secret to lisbon alongside general
castellano
the king's chief negotiator after an
agreement was reached dubat returned to
the uk
on the 28th of august but he only had
the chance to rest for one
month before churchill personally
appointed him as his special
representative to the chinese
nationalist leader
chiang kai-shek
compared to the swash and buckle of
previous years dwight stay in china is
relatively
calm as his mission was more of a
diplomatic one rather than a military
one during this time while advising
chang on his strategies against the
japanese he befriended him
and his wife but when he got to meet mao
well he simply couldn't stand him
the general isimo chiang kai-shek and
chairman mao were uneasy allies in the
war against japan but
duarte he was a staunch anti-communist
and did not trust the future leader of
china mao delivered a lengthy speech on
the qualities of his faction
when he mentioned how hard they were
fighting the japanese dwight cut him
short
he said he tried my credulity a little
too far
i told him that what they were doing was
to keep looking over their shoulder
to see what the generalissimo was doing
first to his surprise mao took no
offense and simply laughed
another leader asked him why hadn't gone
to yannan to see their operations
i answered quite frankly that i hated
communism dwight stayed in china until
1947 surviving yet another plane crash
along the way by the way
and let's add another notch shall we on
the way back to britain duarte paid a
visit
at a friend's house in rangoon burma
while walking down a flight of stairs he
was ambushed by an unpredictable foe
this was actually a coconut mat he slept
on it and went flying down the stairs
breaking a couple of vertebrae along the
way
the good thing is that the doctors
treating his back took the occasion to
remove
quite a bit of old shrapnel from his
body and it was now about time for him
to retire from active duty
general carton dwight finally moved to a
family estate in ireland and spent the
next years there
writing his memoirs hunting fishing and
polishing his collection
of more than 30 medals eventually even
such a legend has to die
after the last few peaceful years adrian
carton dwight's life
it came to an end on june the 5th 1963
in his irish home while in recent years
his achievements have been rediscovered
and celebrated by major media outlets
this
inspiring character is still little
known i hope
that in today's biographics we did our
bit to perpetuate his memory
and we hope that you could do the same
and share this video
frankly i've enjoyed the story of this
gentleman and i hope you did too and
before leaving maybe answer this
question in the comments
if you were to shoot a movie about cart
and dwight who would you like to see
in the lead role and as always please do
hit that like button
subscribe all of that good stuff check
out our wonderful sponsor backblaze
and as always thank you for watching